you see what is wonderful about the kid
we're living now is all these artificial
borders between visual arts photography
design between fashion between
architecture all these artificial
borders are completely disappearing and
for me there's only one thing either
somebody's a great artist or is not so
you have some incredible artists who
express themselves by creating furniture
or objects that you can use in a daily
basis and some artists like the
Australian megastar of the design world
marc newson or the equally great
megastar 1ad are producing unbelievably
beautiful objects that are stunning
sculpture stunning works of art and on
top of that you can sit on them or you
can live with it and so it's and and
nowadays somebody who collects great art
doesn't want to have ugly furniture in
his home or mediocre daily objects he
wants to surround himself with the best
and it has to be challenging stimulating
and exciting whatever it is that you
will surround yourself with
it becomes a work of art when it is
aesthetically pleasing when it is so
extraordinary that you look at it far
beyond its function that you no longer
look at it just as a piece of furniture
better where you think that it's so
stunning that it is a great work of art